أنت في موقف يعاني فيه اقتصادك ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى تحريكه بطريقة أه
أكثر عدوانية من نموه
، واه أنت أه
لا أعتقد أنه يبحث عن حرب باردة
مع الولايات المتحدة
لا أفعل  لا أعتقد أن الأمر يتعلق كما قلت
له ، لقد قلت إن جيلك يفصل بينه وبين
حوالي 10 سنوات ،
هذه ليست لحظة كومبايا كما اعتاد
أن يقول مرة أخرى في الستينيات في الولايات المتحدة
مثل
دعونا نعانق ونحب بعضنا البعض ولكن من
الواضح  ليس في مصلحة أي شخص ،
فإن دولك هي بلدي بالنسبة لنا لنكون
في وضع نشهد
فيه حربًا باردة جديدة وأعتقد حقًا أنه
يعتقد
أنه يفهم أنني تحدثت عن
الاقتراح القائل بأن بعض
البنى التحتية الحيوية يجب أن تكون
خارج نطاق فترة الهجوم  عن طريق الإنترنت أو
بأي وسيلة أخرى أعطيتهم قائمة
إذا لم أكن مخطئًا إذا لم يكن
لدي 16
كيانًا محددًا 16 تم تعريفها على
أنها بنية تحتية مهمة بموجب
سياستنا
من قطاع الطاقة إلى
أنظمة
المياه لدينا بالطبع  المبدأ واحد  الشيء
الذي يجب دعمه من خلال الممارسة ،
تحتاج البلدان المسؤولة إلى اتخاذ
إجراءات ضد المجرمين
الذين يقومون بأنشطة برامج الفدية على
أراضيهم ،
لذلك اتفقنا على خبراء الضرائب
في كل من بلدينا للعمل
على تفاهمات محددة
حول ما هو محظور